les chéris il s'est passé un drame est
aujourd'hui j'adore a besoin de
quelqu'un
j'aurai besoin de quelqu'un
tu vas devoir m'aider
quelqu'un qui va devoir se lancer sur sa
nouvelle carrière
voilà
sachez que j'ai été victime d'un vol
grave tout style aston villa
c'était pas plus tard qu'il ya quelques
minutes voilà
[Musique]
on a volé quelque chose dans ma loge le
montant fait relâche tu auras besoin de
quelqu'un qui sont les choses un
enquêteur hors pair
quelqu'un qui a envie de faire partie de
la police matthieu delormeau
enfin ce que tu veux dire j'aurai besoin
de vous besoin d'un recteur ou de long
il est là puisque ya beaucoup de gens
impliqués depuis ce soir shebab à plein
de gens sur twitter de relance me
questionne sur votre avenir en tant que
policier
parce que oui c'était votre projet
souvenez-vous juste après étant donné
qu'il ya des caméras dans ma loge à à
vous verrez
de quelle larcins j'ai été victime la
ressent longue et la chine à la base
dans mes rêves vous avez toujours voulu
quand j'ai commencé à faire du droit est
commissaire de police ou travailler dans
la police
j'ai toujours voulu faire ça et c'est
vrai que on en prend très peu 1000 à
1200 parents il fallait une maîtrise de
droit
bon il faut que la vie s'est pas fait
comme ça et l'autre jour j'avais au
téléphone mon ami marc olivier fogiel et
je lui ai dit geipan de plus en plus
c'est quelque chose qui me passionne
aujourd'hui je cours plus après l'argent
ou la célébrité je crois pas quelque
chose qui me donnera l'impression de me
réaliser et il m'a dit mais mais il
n'est jamais trop tard français sur la
raison alors voiture je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le bon jour pour
vous lancer dans l'investigation
alors ce qu'importe enjeux de gardiens
de la paix a bien sûr fait pas encore un
avare au château ouais les deux gardiens
de la paix mais pour l'instant vous
allez être gardien de ma loge c'est déjà
beaucoup et gardez de votre coeur
tu es très peur donc mathieu s'était pas
plus tard qu'il ya quelques minutes
regarder chez vous on
quelqu'un m'a volé quelque chose
regardez
[Musique]
quelqu'un a volé un fruit ni dans ma
loge plus précisément une orange
mathieu j'aimerais savoir quels
chroniqueur s'est déguisé ainsi on casa
del papel c'est très simple là vraiment
on commence avec une pour me chaparder 7
orange
mathieu vous êtes un enquêteur hors pair
ouais je crois beaucoup en vous montrer
le prouver le petit à cyril oui la
personne n'a pas de ventre et laisse
belt
c'est donc ni raymond ni jean michel
havard ni benjamin castaldi ni basam un
petit 2 la personne va vite et souple
c'est donc ni mamie à monsieur temps
alors là je vois que c'est pas du voile
a fait le geste le faire qu'on va
retenir ses larmes ali malaisie pas fait
choisi la personne et svelte court
partout on dire en direct regarder
personne et mon fauteuil roulant
j'élimine et mamies et pardon bernard
s'éliminer sexagénaire plus que benali a
généré un texte à jarry c'est que sans
ça que ça s'est sûr c'est que ça allait
tellement lettre officielle après la
machine va falloir la faire grève les
deux sont acceptés sexy cela génère
c'est un mec qui reçoit surtout et qui
mangent des tajines c'est bon si vous
avez donné des cours de français dont
c'est le camembert qui lui auront fort
tu pues voilà merci
c'est donc ni montiel nimani il reste
donc en toute logique bénard ou sophie
et je pense là maintenant j'y vais par
caractère par déduction du caractère je
pense déjà que beynat n'aurait pas pu
cacher son brushing qui coûte si cher
que pour une blague ton prochaine pour
un fruit ne vendrai jamais landreau
chine pour un fruit
même si c'est un fruit défendu
c'est ça c'est mal à connaître
donc il reste une personne qui est assez
jeune qui est bien foutu qui est svelte
qui évoluent ambitieux ambitionne tu
peux rentrer dans une loge est un jeune
chinois de balle avec un brushing à deux
balles qui n'a pas débordé steam pour
les autres ni pour elle je pense donc
assez facilement à sophie koch est ce
que voulaient l'interroger en face à
face pendant 30 secondes
or ce sera facile je sais lire dans les
yeux et pas que allez-y sophie as-tu
volée laurange d'hanouna non as-tu voler
leur ange de nous non non répond sophie
avoue tout de suite ce sera plus simple
je n'ai pas volé le range d'anna si tu
dis la vérité maintenant tu pourra
encore être pardonné dans quelques
minutes ce sera trop tard la sanction
tombera
c'est quoi la sanction cyril hanouna se
chargera la sanction lui-même
ça veut dire qui c'est pas du tout ce
que c'est par le zoo à castaldi n'est
pas d'aujourd'hui annoncé bernard qui
étaient prévues bernard quemada bernard
merdasse et comme c'est que franchement
cm comme un goal aux côtés d' équipe de
france on est ensuite sur l'assaut alors
faute avouée à demi pardonnée et reste
encore dix secondes pour avouer approche
office et vous tu sera officiellement
une voleuse dans toute la france je nie
jusqu'à la tombe
c'est l ennemi en serrant ses mains
comme sa 6000e ferai signe de
culpabilité
elle a peur elle avant que le ciel elle
est coupable donc mathieu vous êtes sûr
que c'est sophie koch 100% brigadier
mathieu vous avez désigné sophie cost
mais pour lille à peut-être une idée
visiblement au lit ouais holly gestuelle
de l'enlever mais vas-y il est venu en
eau et en mai dans toutes ses barres la
montée en niveau 2 par l'histoire
j'aurais dit sophie comme ça d'instinct
paris chéri tu inspires mathieu est
compacte auris est aussi bon enquêteur
que chroniqueur ses animateurs regardez
mathieu ont regardé qui haïssent a volé
laurent chaude hanouna
les volets un volet le orange
je vous jure c'est bien moi qui ai volé
l'orangé regardant après que son bateau
on est parti sur ce délire est qu'à
couper ce matin michel est venu tourner
mogador bischheim il est banni je t'aime
le cheval jeunesse pour faire ça va bien
mais d'imaginaire particulièrement
celles imagine que d'un coup de fil de
cyril hanouna tu t'appelles michal tu te
dis j'ai une production il ya ces huit
qui meurent lance un album c'est hanouna
oui c'est michal tu peux venir faire une
connerie tu vas lune la jeune et que tu
voles une orange déguisé tu te casses le
pas du tout c'est un avant demain paquet
censé lui valoir une orange et puis ça
finit par une panne peut plus vraiment
que tu te la faire pour désigner les
mauvais coups pâle ravaux mathieu
[Applaudissements]